hi i'm jesse i'm a phd student at
cornell and today i'll be talking about
the space complexity of samsung this is
joined to work with ishan chattapatie
and david zuckerman
so complexity theory asks the question
how many computational resources are
required to complete a certain task
traditionally this task has been
computing a boolean function f
and traditionally some computational
resources that have been of particular
interest are time and space
in order to formalize the use of these
resources what we do is we fix a
computational model and that model
usually has some size parameter which
corresponds nicely to one of these
computational resources
so now given a so-called computer from
our computational model we say that it
computes the function f if for every
possible input x the output of c on x is
the same thing as f of x
so given this formalization the question
becomes now what is the smallest c from
our computational class that computes f
and we can call this the complexity of
computing or computational complexity
beyond this task of computing a function
another task that shows up a lot in
computer science is sampling from a
distribution
so it's natural then to wonder how
powerful our favorite computational
models for the alternative task of
sampling
inspired by the works of ambenus
schulman tashma basirani and brakevision
and goldright goldwasser and nussborn
viola launched a systematic study into
this question in 2012.
to formalize this question what we do is
we pick one of our computational models
from before and a so-called computer
from this class
but now instead of giving it a fixed
input x what we give it is a uniformly
random input big x
and we say that c samples the
distribution q if the output
distribution of c on a uniformly random
input is exactly the same as q
so the question here becomes what is the
smallest c from our computational class
that samples the distribution q
and we can call this the complexity of
sampling or the complexity of
distributions
beyond these two specific questions the
complexity of computing and the
complexity of sampling
are generally interested in just
understanding the power of various
computational models for the task of
computing and the task of sampling
in this work we'll focus on
understanding the complexity of sampling
so recently there have been a lot of
really exciting works that further our
understanding of the complexity of
sampling
however while these make really
significant progress results are still
only known for a few computational
models like ac 0 circuits and
communication protocols
and in particular not much is really
known about the complexity of sampling
with limited memory
so in this work we aim to fill this gap
and study the space complexity of
sampling
now before we do so i need to answer two
questions for you
the first one is what should our limited
memory model be
and the second one is what are some
interesting questions to ask about
sampling with this model
so let's understand now what our model
will be
so our model for sampling with limited
memory will just be the standard model
of read once branching programs or robps
a rewards branching program is just a
layered directive directed acyclic graph
the number of layers let's say it's m
we'll call this the input length
and then each layer will have exactly w
nodes which we'll call the width of the
branching program
and there will also be a designated
start vertex v star
each internal node will have exactly two
edges going into the subsequent layer
which it labels with a zero and one
but instead of keeping these labels
around let's just color code the edges
so that the diagram won't get too messy
and finally all of the nodes in the
terminal layer of the robp will label
will be labeled with a bit 0 or 1.
now this rovp computes a function in a
natural way
so given an input x what it does is it
reads it bit by bit and uses these as
instructions for which edge to follow at
each junction
and then finally when it reaches a node
in the terminal layer of the robp it
just outputs the label of that node
so while such an robp can of course
generate a distribution by being said a
uniformly random bit string this
distribution will only be over one bit
because the robp is computing a function
that just outputs one bit
so what we'd like to do is we'd like to
somehow augment this model so that we
can sample distributions over end bits
we need a so-called multi-output robp
so in order to do this the idea is we're
just going to remove the output labels
from the final nodes and then we're
going to add an output label to each
edge in our ovp
and then if we do this our robp will a
compute we'll compute a function that
can help with multiple bits again in the
natural way
so given an input x once again it reads
it bit by bit and uses these as
instructions on which
at for which edge it should take at each
junction
but now when it traverses an edge it
examines what is the output label on
that edge and it appends that to the
output of the program
now it does this reading the input bit
by bit until eventually it reaches the
end of the branching program and it is
outputted all the bits that it is seen
so this is great we now have an robp
that can output multiple bits but one
problem is that the output length of
this robp might not actually be
consistent over all inputs and this is
because different paths in the robp may
actually have different output levels
so what we'd like to do is add just one
small restriction so that the output
length is consistent over all inputs
to do this what we're going to do is for
any two consecutive layers we're going
to require that all of the edges between
them have the have output labels with
the same length say and i
for example maybe all the edges going
between these two layers
have output labels with length 2.
and then we say that the output length
of this robp is just the sum of all the
ms
and now notice that if we feed in a
uniformly random string to our robp we
generate a distribution over n bits
which is what we wanted
so that completes the specification of
our robp and i should note
that this specification is very similar
to multi-output or multi-bit
multi-output robps that were studied in
the 70s and 80s
now i should also note that our main
parameter of interest here will be the
width w of the branching program we
won't be so concerned with the input
length m meaning how many random bits it
will be allowed to use
so that's our limited memory model for
sampling
robps and now we'd like to know what are
some interesting questions to ask about
sampling with robps
to understand what the interesting
questions are
we're going to visit this paradigm that
appears in a lot of papers on the
complexity of sample
which is that sampling in many cases is
actually easier than computing
what i mean by this is that there are
functions such that actually computing
the function on every single possible
input is very hard
but just sampling the output
distribution of this function which is
given a uniform input is very easy
so as an explicit as an example consider
setting f to the inverse of a one-way
permutation of course
it'll be hard to compute f
but the output distribution of f is just
a uniform random variable which is very
easy to sample there are also explicit
examples for ac0 circuits and in our
work we show an explicit example for rob
so because of this it turns out that
sampling lower bound bounds are actually
strictly harder to prove than classical
lower bounds
hence in order to pursue sampling lower
balance we'll need new techniques and it
might be the case that there are
surprising applications and we will see
that that is actually true
so given this our goal is to obtain
sampling lower bounds against robps
we have two main results in this
direction
our first result our very strong
sampling lower bounds against a
meaningful explicit distribution
and our second main result is the
so-called direct product here for
sampling with ropps
so now i'll provide a little bit of
background and formally state each
result
so let's start with our strong lower
bounds
so if we'd like to obtain sampling lower
bounds the first question you should ask
is can we just find a distribution that
cannot be sampled
by our computational model
so one of the first computational models
this question was examined in uh where
ac zero circuits and so here the
question is can we find a distribution q
that cannot be sampled by any ac0
circuit
well it turns out this is actually
trivial uh we can just take a
distribution which assigns an irrational
probability uh to some element in this
support and because the ac 0 circuit is
receiving as input a uniformly random
bit string of length m it cannot
possibly sample an irrational
probability
so the more interesting question raised
by viola in 2012 was can we find a
distribution that cannot even
approximately be sampled by ac0
and by approximately we mean that we
want to find the distribution such that
the output distribution of any ac0
circuit is one minus epsilon far from q
in statistical distance
so this question was answered by lovit
and viola in 2012 where they exhibited a
meaningful explicit distribution that is
uh such that any output distribution of
any ac 0 circuit is polynomially far
from q
and then late a later paper by beck and
pagliaso and love it and prove this
sampling lower bound
to be exponentially to be exponentially
formed so the output distribution of any
ac0 circuit they show that it's
exponentially far from q
and it turns out this was a very natural
distribution it was the uniform
distribution over any good code
so as a reminder a code or an nkd code
is just a subset of bit strings of
length n
it has size 2 to the k
and it gives the guarantee that for any
to the strength
strings in this subset the hamming
distance between them is at least d
and we refer to d as the distance and k
as the dimension of the code
now a good code is just an nkv code
which has constant relative dimension
and constant relative distance
so it should be remarked that while
lovett and viola and beck and pagliazzo
love it show that ac0 circuits cannot
sample good codes it's actually very
easy to show that good codes can be
sampled using communication protocols
and a natural question is then
are good codes hard to sample with robps
so our first main result answers this
question in a positive and we show the
following
for any good code or rather a
distribution uniform over good code
and any robp which has width say 2 to
the 0.01 n
the output distribution of that robp
will be exponentially far from a good
code
so given a connection made by viola in
2012 our result also has applications to
data structure lower bounds for storing
code words
so that's our first main result now our
second main result is a direct product
theorem for sampling with robps
so given that we want to pursue sampling
lower bounds
a natural question is if we have a
distribution that's a little bit hard to
sample for a computational class
can we somehow use it to build another
distribution that is very hard to sample
for that class
and even more so we're wondering can we
build from q a distribution q star that
is just slightly more complex but that
is much harder to sample
and if we can find such a q star then
we'll be able to strengthen known
separations between complexity classes
in order to answer this question or this
question is directly answered by direct
product students
so in the context of computing a direct
product theorem is roughly defined as
follows
so it says the following so suppose that
you have a function f that is hard to
compute for the class c
then it says that you can build a
function f cross t that is very hard to
compute for the class c as follows
so f cross p will take its input it'll
chop it up into two parts
and then it'll just apply the hard
function f to each part
and that's what a direct product theory
is and a very well known direct product
theorem is yao's exorbitant
in the context of sampling a direct
product theorem might be defined as
follows
so suppose that you have a distribution
that is hard to sample for a class c
then we'd like to build a distribution q
cross t that is very hard to sample for
c and a good candidate distribution is
just taking t independent copies of q
and concatenating them together
however while this is a relatively
natural question there are actually no
known direct product theorems for the
task of sampling
and so what we'd like to know then is
can we establish a direct product
theorem for sampling and in particular
for robps
so our second main result establishes
such a theorem
we show the following
if it holds that for any with wrobp
its output distribution is delta far
from the distribution q
then it holds that for any with wrobp
its output distribution is exponentially
far from the distribution to cross t
so that's our second main result
so just to summarize everything
our main result is a sampling lower
bound against good codes and a direct
product here
so previously sampling lower bounds
against good codes were known for ac0
circuits
and it is known and not too hard to show
that communication protocols can
actually very easily sample good codes
our first main result shows that robps
have a very very hard time sampling good
codes
and using a connection by viola we
obtain data structure lower bounds for
storing codewords
now in terms of a direct product theorem
nothing was actually known for any
computational model for the task of
sampling
and our second main result establishes
this direct product theorem for robps
and what's cool is that along the way
one of our key ingredients actually
gives a simple new proof of results by
boost and watson for sampling disjoint
tests using communication protocols
so those are our two main
results in the remainder of this talk
i'll provide proof sketches of our two
main results
we'll start with our sampling lower
bounds against good codes
the proof of our sampling lower bounds
relies on three key ingredients
the first key ingredient roughly says
that a convex combination of
distributions
each far from some target distribution q
is itself far from the target
distribution cube
the second key ingredient says that
distribution sampled by low with robps
are a convex combination of so-called
low-width product distributions
and the third key ingredient which is
the main ingredient in this proof
says that low-width product
distributions are far from good coats
now given these three key ingredients
it's easy to obtain our sampling lower
bounds for robps against good coats
in particular by by combining ingredient
2 and ingredient 3 we get that
distribution sampled by low with robps
are a convex combination of
distributions that are far from good
codes
and then by applying ingredient 1 we get
that distribution sampled by low with
robps are themselves far from good codes
so
all that remains is to dive into these
three ingredients
we'll start with ingredient one which
says that a convex combination of far
distributions is far
so recall that a distribution x is a
convex combination of distributions x1
through xt
if it can be written in the following
form where x samples from x i with
probability
pi now a standard fact about convex
combination that's not too difficult to
prove
is that a convex combination of close
distributions is close
meaning that if we can write x as a
convex combination of distributions x i
and each x i is delta close to x then it
follows that x itself is delta close to
x
and moreover the proof is not too hard
to show it follows from a relatively
straightforward application of the
triangle inequality
but recall that this isn't what we
wanted to show for our ingredient we
wanted to kind of show off
we wanted to show that a convex
combination of far distributions was far
meaning that if we can write x as a
convex combination of distribution x i
and each x i is delta far from the
distribution q
does it follow that x itself is delta
far from the distribution q
well it's not hard to show that this is
blatantly wrong
and for the following reason
suppose that we let i range over the
support of our random variable q
and then for each i we define a random
variable x i
which is constantly equal to i
and then finally we define a probability
p i which is just the probability that q
equals i
so if we consider the convex combination
defined over these things
we get that x exactly samples q
on the other hand as long as q is not a
constant random variable
each x i will have statistical distance
strictly greater than zero from q
meaning that this statement can't
possibly be true
so you might be wondering what's the
deal because this is our first key
ingredient well this is where the
asterisk comes into play hidden behind
the asterisk is the statement
provided there are not too many
participants in the convex combination
so more formally now our ingredient one
says the following it says suppose we
have a distribution x that can be
written as a convex combination of
distributions x i
and suppose that each x i is one minus
delta far from the distribution q
and furthermore suppose they're that
they're at most key participants in the
convex combination
then it follows that the original
distribution x is one minus t times
delta far from q
now this is just a slight generalization
of a lemma proven by viola
where it was required that each pi was
the same
so that completes our discussion of
ingredient one now we move on to discuss
ingredient two which says that
distribution sampled by low with robps
are a convex combination of so-called
low-width product distributions
now this was a this result was proven in
all alternative language by konig and
moore and camp rao vadon
and so in order to prove this result
let's recall that a random variable x
samples a product distribution if it can
be written as a concatenation of r
independent chunks
each an independent random variable over
l bits
and of course we require that r times l
equals n
now we say that the product distribution
has low width if the number of bits in
each chunk is not too much that is if l
is small
so now that we know what a low width
product distribution is let's revisit
the ingredient that we want to prove
so let's recall what a low with robp
looks like and let's recall how it
samples the distribution
well what it does is it takes in a
uniformly random bit string y
and it follows the path whose colors
match the input bits in y
and then it simply outputs the output
bits it sees on the edges along the way
now if you think a little bit there's
actually a different way to describe
this process that doesn't have to do
with input at all
so what we can do is we can disregard
any input and we can instead just and
any colors on the edges as well and we
can instead just start at the designated
start vertex take a uniformly random
walk along the branching program and
output the output bits it sees along the
way
and notice that this is actually going
to sample an equivalent distribution
an exact exactly the same distribution
and even more so this alternative
interpretation will make it much easier
to prove our second ingredient
so given this alternative interpretation
let's now consider some layer perhaps
the middle layer and consider
conditioning on hitting some fixed node
v in that middle layer
well if you think about a little it
turns out given this conditioning the
distribution x actually gets split up
into two independent parts x1 and x2
and furthermore if you take a random
walk over this branching program it's
guaranteed that it will hit exactly one
vertex in this layer always
and so by considering all possible
conditionings over these vertices we see
that x is a convex combination of
distributions of this same form
moreover since there are w
vertices in this layer the convex
combination will have w distributions in
it
and furthermore we can assume without
loss of generality that each independent
chunk
within x
is over n over 2 bits because if this is
not the case we can easily perform some
sort of pre-processing operations on our
robp before we begin to fit out
so next let's consider a slightly more
general idea which is to condition on
hitting some sequence of nodes across
our layers
now it's relatively straightforward to
extend the previous argument to say that
if you consider all possible
conditionings of this form we see that x
is actually a convex combination of
distributions each consisting of r
independent chunks
and the number of elements or
participants in this convex combination
is exactly w to the r because that is
the number of possibilities of fixings
of these vertices across all these r
layers
and furthermore for the same reasons as
before we can assume without loss of
generality that each chunk in there has
the same number of bits in it namely l
which is n over r
so now what we'd like to do is we'd like
to pick an r so that two things are true
we'd like l to be small because we want
to show that it's a convex combination
of low width product distribution
and second we'd like w r to be w to the
r to be small because eventually we're
going to invoke our first ingredients
and recall that our first ingredient in
this proof relies on bounding the number
of participants in the convex
combination and this is how many
participants we have in this complex
combination
but you might be a little wary because
we know that r times l equals n so one
of these things can't be too small
but it turns out if we just ensure that
the width w of the branching program is
not too big we can make sure that both
of these quantities at least don't get
too ridiculously huge
so that concludes our discussion of our
second key ingredient and now we move to
talk about our third and final and main
key ingredient that low with product
distributions are far from good codes
so here we have one main key idea which
is a sort of anti-concentration result
of product distributions and hamming
balls so let me explain what i mean by
that
so recall that a hamming ball centered
at v with the radius r
is just a collection of all strings that
have hamming distance at most r from v
now consider a product distribution x
which satisfies some sort of basic
non-triviality conditions
what our key idea says that says is that
if you look at the probability mass that
x assigns to a ball
most of it is actually not going to be
on the center of the ball
and this is where our sort of
anti-concentration result comes from
so given this key idea how can we use it
to prove ingredients three
well the idea is to consider our nkt
code and now by the distance property of
the code what we can do is we can draw
disjoint balls
around each code word of radius just
slightly less than d over 2.
and now if we consider a product
distribution x
by our anti-concentration result our key
idea
we can say that actually almost all the
probability mass that x assigns to the
space
is missing the code q it's missing these
center points
and so we can then conclude that x must
be relatively far from the uniform
distribution over the code q
so now that we know what our key ideas
and how it can be used to prove
ingredient three we're going to give a
formal statement of this key idea and a
proof sketch
so the formal statement is as follows so
suppose you have a product distribution
which consists of r chunks each over l
bits
and of course again we always have r
times l equals n
now it says that for any ball with the
radius big l which is just some valid
integer multiple of little l
the following inequality holds it says
the probability that x hits the center
of the ball
divided by the probability that x hits
the ball itself is upper bounded by this
quantity
so in particular the smaller this
expression is on the left the stronger
the anti-concentration result is because
it's saying there's a lot of weight in
the ball that is not landing on the set
the smaller that this gets
so given this if we'd like to apply it
in order to obtain ingredient three
we actually need to have we need to be
examining it for a ball with radius and
big l that is strictly less than d over
two and that's because recall in our
proof of ingredient three we're drawing
balls around the code words of radius
less than d over two to make sure they
don't intersect
so we therefore also need little l to be
at most d over two
but this is taken care of by the
assumption that we're in a low width
product distribution
so next we have some desires so our
first desire is that we want actually
big l to be large even though we have
this kind of strict upper bound
well it turns and the reason we want
this to be large is because recall that
we want this expression to be small that
corresponds to a stronger
anti-concentration result
and since this is a probability on the
right here between 0 and 1
the bigger l is the smaller this
quantity will become
well it turns out that this
strict kind of upper bound on big l is
not that big of a deal because we're
dealing with good codes namely codes
that have distance that's linear in n
which means that we can actually make
this power a constant that's bounded
away from zero
so our second desire is we want the
probability
that x hits the center of the ball to be
as small as possible because again
that's going to minimize this expression
on the left here
well it turns out that this should be
true for most of the code words and
that's just because the code has good
dimension
namely it has a lot of code words
so now now that we know what our
anti-concentration result is
and how it can be used
we're going to prove it
so the proof goes as follows so we're
going to use the letter v to represent
the center of our ball
we'll color code it appropriately
so
let's start with the trivial lower bound
on the probability that x hits the ball
so of course the probability that x hits
the ball is at least the probability
that x hits the center of the ball right
and since x is a product distribution
that probability is exactly equal to
this
but we can do something smarter here
right
so what we can do is we can say the
following
for any subset of coordinates of size c
if we consider an x
that matches the center of the ball v
on all chunks i
falling outside of this set s
it must follow that x is in the ball
and the reason for this is the only
places where x does not exactly match b
are the chunks
labeled by an index i that is non-s
well there are c such indices and each
chunk contains l bits so x can differ
from the center of the ball by at most c
times l locations
which is at most the radius of the ball
so therefore x is in the ball
now given this observation we can lower
bound the probability that x is in the
ball by something more clever than this
original probability namely we can
remove from the product all the
probabilities
equal to of the form x i equals v i
where i
is in the set s
and now a simple inequality or simple
equality is that this is exactly the
same thing as the probability that x
hits the center of the ball divided by
the probability that each coordinate i
in x
each coordinate i and s
labels a chunk in x
that
exactly matches the corresponding chunk
at the center of the
ball so now in order to conclude this
and provide a strong lower bound on this
expression we want to provide an upper
bound on this expression
and in order to do this all you have to
do is let s
be the set that minimizes this quantity
on the left here
and through a quick calculation you can
show that this is exactly upper bounded
by the quantity we want
and then by rearranging terms we get our
result
so that completes the proof of our key
idea
and we've already seen how it can be
used to obtain ingredient three
so that concludes our discussion of
ingredient three
and now since ingredient three was the
last ingredient that went into our main
results one
we finish our proof of our sampling
lower bounds for robps against good
codes
next we give a proof of our direct
product theorem
recall that it says the following
suppose that we have some distribution q
such that for any width of wrobp
the output distribution of that robp is
delta far from q
then it follows that for any width w
robp the output distribution of it is
exponentially far from the distribution
q cross t
and recall that we define q cross t
to just be p independent copies of q
concatenated together
now the proof of our direct product
theorem goes via two key ingredients
the first key ingredient is kind of a
more general direct product theorem that
works for any distribution family
satisfying a special
so-called slice property which we'll
define in a
moment then the second key ingredient is
a proof that the family of distribution
sampled by with wrobps
has the slice property
and so by combining these two
ingredients we immediately obtain our
direct product theorem for sampling with
robps
so all that remains is to dive into
these two ingredients and we'll start by
looking at ingredient one which is our
more general direct product theorem
so formally it states the following
suppose we have some distribution q and
some family curly x which satisfies the
slice property
then if it holds that every distribution
in this family is delta far from q
it follows that every distribution in
this family is exponentially far from
the distribution 2 cross t
so that's the theorem and now i can
finally tell you what the slice property
is
so we say that the family curly x has a
slice property if the existence of a
distribution x in this family implies
the existence of this related
distribution in this family
and let me tell you how this related
distribution is constructed and defined
so first consider the distribution x or
rather the random variable x
then we define x sub i to j
to be the slice of x going from
coordinates i to j meaning we're going
to cut off all bits coming before
coordinate i and all bits coming after
coordinate j
then finally we define x sub i to j to
the z
as this slice conditioned on fixing the
bits coming before i to the value z
and so that's the slice property and
note that it has to hold for all
possible i j and c
and if you want a formal definition of
this related random variable i can flash
one up on the screen here
so in order to prove this theorem we we
proved a simple new lemma on amplifying
statistical distance
so it looks something like the following
so
suppose that you have any distribution q
and any distribution y which consists of
t independent distributions concatenated
together
furthermore suppose that each y i is
delta far from q
then it follows that the original
distribution y consisting of all the y
is concatenated together is
exponentially far from the distribution
q cross t
now i sort of lied so this is a very uh
well-known lemma and it has a fun proof
but it doesn't actually work for what we
need in order to prove our theorem
so we need to prove a similar lemma that
kind of works for a sequence of somewhat
dependent random variables so we'd like
to get rid of this condition here
so our new key lemma shows how to do
this and we do this just by
strengthening the hypothesis of this
lemon just by a little bit
so instead of requiring that each y i is
delta far from q we have a slightly
stronger requirement that each y i to
the z is delta far from q
and here y i to the z means y i
conditioned on the bits before it being
fixed to z
so the proof of this result is a little
difficult if you try to do it using
statistical distance but it turns out to
admit a pretty clean uh short proof if
you instead consider more amenable
notions of distance such as the body
charging coefficient
then given this simple new lemma the
proof for our theorem is immediate and
it goes as follows
so what we'd like to do is we'd like to
take some arbitrary x prime in our
family curly x which has the slice
property and lower bound the statistical
distance between x prime and q cross t
in order to do this the first
observation is that the distribution x
prime or rather the random variable x
prime can be parsed in this form as
t consecutive random variables
each n bits law
now what we'd like to do is somehow
argue that this hypothesis of the lemma
must hold
well notice that y i to the z is
actually the same thing as taking a
slice of x-prime and pre-conditioning it
conditioning the bits that come before
the slice to be fixed to something
but notice that such a distribution must
be in the family curly x because it has
the slice problem
and thus by the hypothesis
of this theorem we must have this basic
lower bound on statistical distance
and then we can use this to obtain the
hypothesis of our key lemma
and thus we obtain the conclusion of our
t lemma which is the exact same thing as
the conclusion of our theorem and that
proves the theorem
and that completes our discussion of
ingredient one which is our general
direct product theorem for distribution
families with the slice property
so now we move to talk about our key
ingredient two which shows that the
family of distribution sampled by with
the wrotp has a slice property
so
recall that the slice property says that
if the distribution x is in the family
it's required that this related
distribution is also in this family so
it has this certain closure property
and in the context of robps what we'd
like to show is that if there's a
distribution x sampleable by with wrobps
then the distribution x from i to j
conditioned on fixing the bits before i
to z should also be sampleable by with
wrobps
so the key tool that we'll use to show
this is the construction of a width to
robp that can sample an arbitrary
distribution over one bit
or rather it can come arbitrarily close
to sampling such a distribution
in order to construct this with wrobp
the key idea is to encode the so-called
success probability of this target
distribution
as a bit string namely as its boolean
representation
up to you know some certain precision
desired precision
then we're going to use this bit string
as instructions to construct our robp
in particular each bit in the string
will tell us how we should draw the
edges between a certain pair of lights
and that's a key idea and it ends up
working out for constructing such a with
two more obp
so then we're going to use this key tool
as a module to construct more general
with wrobp that can sample an arbitrary
distribution over this larger alphabet w
and given our width to robp it's
actually not too difficult to do just by
concatenating these with two modules in
kind of an overlapping sequence
structure
so now that we have a with wrobp that
can sample an arbitrary distribution z
or rather for any arbitrary distribution
d we have a with wrobp that sample it
what we're going to do is we're going to
show the slice property
so suppose that we have an arbitrary
distribution x and it's sampleable by
with wrobps for example maybe this is
our obp that samples it
we want to somehow perform surgery on it
to create a with a wrobp that samples
this related distribution
so we're going to do so as follows so
first of all we can assume without loss
of generality
that each edge in this robp the output
bit on it uh the output label on it is
just one bit and if this is not the case
it's easy to do some sort of
pre-processing pre-processing
to make sure that this happens
so given such an robp we're going to
focus on layers i and j and we're going
to completely remove the part of the
robp that comes before i the part of the
robp that comes after j
and after this uh note that since we
want to not just sample the slice from i
to j we want to sample the slice from i
to j conditioned on this fixing
what we need is we need to somehow
construct a with w module that simulates
what happens when we fix these first few
output bits to be z
so given our with wrobp that can sample
any distribution d we can construct a
with w module that does exactly that
so we're going to use this module to
replace the original part of the robp
and stitch it on to the layer i
and it is then not too difficult to show
that this new robp is sort of
frankenstein robp
is the exact distribution we were
targeting thereby showing that the
family of distribution sample sampleable
but with the wrotps has the slice
property
so that completes our overview of
ingredient 2 and since we know that
ingredient 1 and ingredient 2
immediately prove our direct product
theorem we're done with our proof sketch
for our direct product theorem
so that completes our proof sketches of
our two main results
to conclude we proved sampling lower
bounds against good codes for robp
we approved the direct product theorem
for the task of sampling with robps
previously sampling lower bounds against
good codes were only known for ac0
circuits and in fact it's easy to show
that communication protocols have no
trouble sampling good codes
in this work we show that robps are more
like ac 0 circuits for the task in that
they have a very hard time sampling good
codes
in particular we show that for any good
code and for any robp of width say 2 to
the 0.01 n
it holds that the output distribution of
that robp is exponentially far from the
good code
and in fact the sampling lower bounds
that we get are even a little bit
stronger than the best known for ac 0
circuits
now using a known connection from viola
we automatically also get data structure
lower bounds for the task of storing
coghlins
in the context of our direct product
theorem previously no direct product
theorems were known for the task of
sampling in any computational model
in this work we give the first result of
such a type and we prove a direct
product theorem for the task of sampling
with robps
in particular we show that for any
distribution q if we can show that any
with wrobp outputs a distribution that
is delta far from q then we can conclude
that any with wrobp
outputs a distribution that is
exponentially far from the distribution
two cross t
and one nice thing about this proof is
that along the way we use a simple new
key ingredient that also allows us to
give a simple new proof of a known
result by goose and watson on sampling
disjoint sets using communication
protocols
now since this is a very new area the
complexity of sampling a lot of
interesting open problems remain
for example it would be cool to see if
we could prove a direct product theorem
for other computational models such as
ac0 circuits
given our technique for proving the
direct product theorem for sampling with
robps to prove a direct product theorem
for sampling with ac 0 circuits it would
suffice to show that ac0 circuits have
the slice property
next it would be interesting to
generalize our robp sampling lower
bounds to read k branching programs
a lot of our lower bounds depend on
being able to cut up the robp into
independent parts and this is much more
difficult to do when you allow it to
read an input bit more than once
finally it would be interesting to see
if we can prove separations between
sampling with ac0 circuits and with
robps
in particular it is actually easy to
show a distribution that can be sampled
with ac 0 circuits but is very hard
example of robps
on the other hand
it could be more interesting to try to
understand if there's a distribution
that can be sampled with robps that
cannot be sampled with ac0 circuits in
order to do this one thing that would be
one thing that would suffice would be
to construct a randomness extractor for
distributions generated by ac0 circuits
such that the randomness extractor can
be computed by a read once branching
program
however it turns out that all known
extractors right now that work for
distributions generated by ac0 circuits
also work for distributions generated by
robps so right now our current
extractors cannot work and new ideas are
needed
so that concludes my talk thanks for
stopping by and i hope you enjoyed it